doch mein youtube analysen sehen mich
gerade 80 prozent von euch auf ihrem
handy oder um genau zu sein auf ihrem
smartphone wenn ein handy ist spätestens
seit dem steve jobs am 29 06 2007 das
iphone angekündigt hat schon lange nicht
mehr nur ein telefon
ich benutze ein handy für fotos e-mails
nachrichten als wecker e-book-reader
tourkalender taschenrechner taschenlampe
navi scanner für meine notizen als
fotoalbum videos zu schauen all das
werde ich in zukunft vermissen denn für
die nächste woche wenn ich mein handy
kein einziges mal benutzen
dieses video wird unterstützt von 9 und
schielt das brauche ich dann jetzt nicht
mehr
[Musik]
inzwischen da ich mein handy für fast
alles benutzt muss ich als erstes nach
alternativen schauen
mein erster kontakt mit meinem handy ist
ganz in der früh wenn es nicht auf weg
dafür habe ich mir ganz klassisch einen
analogen becker bestellt danach mache
ich mich in bad fertig und höre musik um
diese woche nicht kommt der dorfmusik zu
verzichten kann ich zumindest zu hause
den sendern eines mikrofons dafür
missbrauchen den ton meines computers
kabellos an meine kopfhörer zu senden
anschließend mache ich mich an die
arbeit
ich habe mein kalender natürlich auch am
pc aber damit ich auch unterwegs weiß
was als nächstes ansteht verwende ich ab
jetzt einen analogen wochen planer einen
alten taschenrechner habe ich hier falls
ich etwas ausrechnen muss um zu wissen
wie spät es ist habe ich mir eine
armbanduhr zugelegt was ich ohnehin
schon tun wollt e-mails whatsapp und
youtube wird es für mich in zukunft wohl
nur noch am pc geben ich habe jetzt
weniger als zwei stunden kein handy und
es fühlt sich einfach jetzt komisch an
vor allem auf der toilette ist es immer
so
ich sitze jetzt hier
ja ich große dass man schon nach zwei
stunden zu entzugserscheinungen hat da
ich heute den ganzen tag mit drehen
beschäftigt bin kommen die
entzugserscheinungen aber erstaunlich
selten ich hätte heute wahrscheinlich
ohnehin wenig auf mein handy geschaut
aber es war tatsächlich ein komisches
gefühl fünf stunden lang unterwegs zu
sein ohne prozent nachrichten lesen und
schreiben zu können jetzt muss nur noch
der weg für morgen gestellt werden ich
musste mir jetzt will den weg wirklich
einfach die anleitung durch lesen weil
ich so ein ding noch nie eingestellt
habe ich hoffe einfach mal dass ich das
ding jetzt morgen um sieben uhr morgens
aufweckt ganz ohne handy im schlafzimmer
zu legen ist auf eine komische art und
weise ein beruhigendes gefühl auf der
einen seite schränkt mich das natürlich
ein aber es nimmt mir warum auch immer
sehr viel stress von den schultern
[Musik]
wtf sollte das ding ich schon lange
kaputt sein
ach ja stimmt ich stehe auf und putze
mir die zähne musik hören ohne handy
funktioniert recht gut aber ich kann
natürlich den song nicht wechseln ohne
zum pc zu gehen und wenn ich den müll
rausbringen die wäsche macht oder ganz
einfach draußen bin bricht die
verbindung meiner beiden seien dann
natürlich ab ich habe es ja schon mal in
einem video gesagt anschließend ist ein
komplett verrückter sein frühstück ohne
sich dabei ein youtube video anschauen
und das mache ich gerade auch das klingt
jetzt für manche von euch vielleicht
verrückt aber ich finde es echt
ungewohnt nicht am handy zu sein wenn
ich alleine und ließ deswegen einfach
ein buch dabei welche sich ohnehin schon
lange hätte fertig lesen sollen das
komische gefühl überhaupt ist es
übrigens da raus zu sein ohne handy
gestern hat ja immer noch mal ein
kameramann barney dabei und da hat er
auf dem handy aber jetzt ich hab kein
telefon kein navi kann jemanden anrufen
ich kann auch niemand anrufen im notfall
klar wie hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass jetzt heute notfall passieren ich
weiß schon aber es ist trotzdem kommen
man fühlt sich irgendwie nackt aber auch
irgendwo frei weil ich hatte einfach
niemanden anrufen kann
egal wie wichtig irgendwas ist zu hause
angekommen checke ich endlich meine
nachrichten am computer ich kann auch
endlich wieder nach meinem youtube-kanal
schauen ich schaue noch mal gerne
einfach mal zwischendurch auf mein handy
wie meine videos laufen und was die
leute kommentieren das mache ich jetzt
aber viel seltener einfach weil ich die
funktion dafür am handy viel angenehmer
finde das fühlt sich komisch an
ich meine klar ich will das nicht
sowieso nicht nutzen aber allein die
tatsache dass es kann nicht nicht mal in
diesem raum ist entspannt mich irgendwie
echt ziemlich aufstehen mit dem analogen
welt ist echt erfrischend normal ich
weiß gar nicht beschreiben soll aber
normal wenn ich aufstehe gehe ich immer
kurz ans handy und scrolling die
kurzwelle durch soll komisch es klingt
kitschig aber keine ahnung ich bin jetzt
hier und jetzt wie ihr seid meine wieder
maske video wisst liebe ich erstmal eine
woche bis ins letzte detail zu planen
das planen nach ich nach wie vor am ball
konnte das jetzt schon wieder halten
aber auch einfach alles aus wo waren wir
das plan mache ich nach wie vor am pc
aber um auch von unterwegs darauf
zurückgreifen zu können
übertrage ich mein zeitplan auf papier
das problem dabei ist natürlich dass
materie nicht einfach hin und
herschieben kann wenn sich etwas im plan
ändert es gibt etwas unerfreuliche
nachrichten also wie soll ich das jetzt
sagen also ich hab eine stromrechnung
bekommen und das geld muss halt am 22
erster bei denen überwiesen sein ja also
normal über weiß ich halt immer per
online-banking vom handy aus ihr fragt
euch jetzt bestimmt
hey wieso gehst du nicht alle banken und
überweist wie jeder normale mensch auch
ich habe mein bankkonto immer noch in
bayern in meinem heimatort und scheinbar
ist es so dass ich einfach nicht warum
auch immer
von irgendwo anders überweisen kann
außer online ich kann es auch vom pc
beweisen jedoch bräuchte dann trotzdem
lab in die mir ans handy geschickt wird
und wenn ich dann nach diesem experiment
wieder mein handy benutzen darf ist es
wochenende das heißt da wird eh keine
überweisungen mehr bearbeitet dann
daraus noch mal ein bis zwei tage und
deswegen wird mit der rechnung ein
bisschen kritisch
also jetzt wird's lustig ich muss
nämlich für ein meeting in die
paulinstraße 37 und ich kenne mich in
können wir gebrauchen also schon gar
nicht kann ich irgendwie über in dem
straßen noch mal will ich damit google
maps den finden ja ganz einfach handy
habe ich natürlich nicht deswegen hier
eine karte und ich muss auch zugeben
dass ich noch nie in meinem leben eine
gerade benutzt habe wie groß ist
irgendwann hahnenstraße wie man bereits
jetzt müssen wir das ganze als erstes
mal finden
ich habe zugegeben noch nie wirklich
eine landkarte oder stadtkarte benutzt
weswegen sich das schwieriger
herausstellt als erwartet tann straße
gut nach hausmann stellt sich jetzt
nicht darauf hätte ich auch nie denken
kann
ich glaube ich muss nicht auf die straße
auf und ab laufen besucher ja gut dann
mache ich mir jetzt mal auf dem weg mit
dieser riesigen landkarte ich will gar
nicht wissen wie das aussieht auf der
straße und was die leute von mir denken
[Musik]
nur knapp wenig der kompletten blamage
ausgewichen in dem ich meine karte
zusammengefaltet habe dennoch streifen
mich einige fragwürdige blicke meiner
zeitgenossen wehre mich die karte auf
meinem weg zum treffpunkt zielsicher
durch die stadt bringt also ich jetzt
hier schon eine weile im können diese
einen straße entlang und die frage ist
hat sich als band muss ich abwägen also
ich sag mal so hier ist die maastricht
heerstraße das heißt dass sich quasi
genau hier bin auf der karte das ist
schon mal schön zu wissen und das heißt
aber hat er sich hier die nächste nach
links abbiegen muss ich glaube dass das
könne theoretisch müsste ich jetzt
gleich da sein sofern das die richtige
straße überhaupt ist ich habe ja nicht
mal ein straßenschild und deswegen
hatten jetzt einfach mal dass ich nicht
in der falschen straße bin und ich mich
nicht verirrt haben und jetzt gleich da
bin
wenige auch wirklich bitter erreiche ich
den treppen auch wenn ich durch dieses
experiment in beinahe allen bereichen
meines lebens eingeschränkt bin fühle
ich mich ohne handy weniger gestresst
als mit und das obwohl das handy
eigentlich zeit sparen sollte selbst
jetzt am letzten tag erwische ich mich
immer noch dabei wie ich leicht panisch
meine hosen taschen ab taste und denke
dass ich mein handy irgendwo verloren
habe aber ich glaube das ist normal
obwohl jetzt wirklich interessant wenn
mit einer landkarte durch köln zu laufen
muss man sich glaube ich eingestehen
dass manche technologien der
vergangenheit angehören und das auch
gute gründe hat abgesehen davon dass
eure privatsphäre natürlich mit der
landkarte deutlich besser geschützt ist
also mit einem handy es ist auch nicht
schlecht dass immer und überall musik
hören zu können ohne einen mp3-player
oder in meinem fall einen funkstrecken
mikrofon zu haben obwohl mich der mangel
an musik diese auch bisschen mehr
wertschätzen liest werde ich auf jeden
fall trotzdem weiterhin immer und
überall musik hören unterwegs erreichbar
zu sein ist nichts schlechtes und ich
denke aber da habe ich eh schon die
perfekte balance gefunden indem ich
quasi mein handy ein brauch sturm
gestalten hat und sogar vibrationen aus
und ich das nur mit krieg wenn ich aufs
handy cook alle paar minuten wo man
handy aber definitiv nichts mehr zu
suchen hat ist das schlafzimmer diese
unglaubliche innere ruhe
und dieses gefühl welches ich selbst
nach einer woche nur mit ich bin jetzt
hier und entspannen mich und nichts auf
dieser welt kann mich davon abhalten ja
dieses gefühl ist es nicht wert
unterbrochen zu werden noch nicht einmal
dadurch alle kommunikation unterhaltung
und das ganze wissen der welt neben
seinem bett liegen zu haben tut eure
medien gefallen und holt eine hülle
damit das teil nicht kaputt geht
ihr wisst ja jetzt woanders ist eine
woche ohne handy auskommen zu müssen und
auch dass die warnung schild höhlen
einiges aushalten
genauso wichtig ist es einen bildschirm
zu haben ich habe ja die impact
protection drauf check den link in der
video beschreibung aus und benutzt den
code comrie um diese woche 20 prozent
auf alle hüllen und alles andere zu
verleihen und viel zu sparen
nächste woche kommt ein video in dem ich
in einer woche über 100 stunden arbeit
also wenn ihr das nicht verpassen möchte
hat dann aber nicht gerne sind kanal und
dann sehen wir zunächst mal wieder alles
gut
[Musik]
ja